If you got 12 pounds, nice work. When approaching this problem, we can think
about combining the like terms or the like weights on one side. I can combine
the m's as like terms, so I'll have 3 m on this side and 2 m on this side. I can
also combine the 200 and the 50. These are both like terms since they're just
numbers. 200 and 38 are also like terms. I can add those weights together. So, I
have 238 plus 3 m is equal to 250 plus 2 m. I have 238 plus 3 m is equal to 250
plus 2 m. We know we can remove weights from both sides so we can take off a 2
m, from here and here. I remove 2 m from the weights and 2 m from the weights
over here. So, I'm just left with 238 plus m equals 250. I want to think of
about getting m alone. I want to isolate this variable. I want to figure out how
much this weighs. So, I should remove 238 pounds from both sides. We could
easily think about removing 200 and 200, and then removing 38, and removing 38
from 50. So, we know one way m is equal to 12 pounds. When looking back at our
work, we should always remember that we're trying to isolate m. You want to
remove the variable from both sides and remove constants from both sides.
Eventually, we want the variable on one side and constants on the other. We
could have done this in a reverse order and maybe you did it a little bit
differently. That's okay. We just want to make sure we are performing the same
steps and reasoning through our results. When solving the equation, we always
want to start off by combining like terms. This helps us know what to remove
from both sides of the equation. We could have removed the numbers from both
sides of the equation first. That's okay. We just need to be consistent and
always remove or perform the same operation on both sides of the equation at
each step.